Willkommen an der Theresianischen Militärakademie
in Wiener Neustadt. Mein Name ist Oberst Markus
Reisner, ich bin der Leiter der Forschungs-
und Entwicklungsabteilung und heute wollen
wir uns in einem neuen Video ansehen, wie sich
die derzeitige Situation im Donbass darstellt:
Was wissen wir und was können wir bereits über den
Verlauf der Schlacht um den Donbass sagen? Als Erstes
kurz eine Orientierung: Was geschah in den letzten
Wochen? In den letzten Wochen war es der Fall,
dass die russische Offensive im Norden der Ukraine
gescheitert ist und es zu einer Verlagerung der
russischen Kräfte in den Osten kam. Hier wurde
von russischer Seite ausgedrückt, dass das neue
Ziel der Operationsführung die Einkesselung der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte im Donbass sei. Das
heißt, das Schwergewicht der letzten Wochen war
im Prinzip die Kampfführung der russischen Seite
hier im Donbass, dem jetzt von ukrainischer Seite
versucht wird, entgegenzuhalten. Eine Operation
kann man in drei Phasen unterteilen: Die erste
Phase ist die sogenannte Vorbereitung oder Shaping
Phase. Diese Vorbereitungsphase hat sich dadurch
ausgedrückt, dass die russische Seite versucht
hat, 50.000 bis 60.000 Soldaten, die bereits
geschwächt waren von den Kämpfen im Raum Kiew,
über 1.000 Kilometer mit der Eisenbahn
zu verlegen, in den Osten der Ukraine,
und dort die Voraussetzungen zu schaffen für
die Einsatzführung. Während dies geschah - Ende
März / Anfang April - hat man weiters versucht
zu verhindern, dass die ukrainische Seite in
Vorbereitung auf diese Schlacht Kräfte nachführt.
Das heißt, man hat mit Luftangriffen versucht,
diese Versorgungslinien zu unterbrechen. Die
entscheidende Phase hat dann knapp Mitte April
begonnen und das war der Versuch der russischen
Seite, die Kräfte der Ukraine an der Kontaktlinie
einzukesseln. Es gab hier zwei Optionen: Eine
Umfassung in der Tiefe, angelehnt an den Dnjepr,
oder eine kurze Umfassung. Es kristallisiert
sich heraus, dass wir in den letzten Tagen
diese kurze Umfassung sehen, wo man mit einer
nördlichen Zange und Kräfte-Bereitstellung und
einer südlichen Zange und Kräfte-Bereitstellung
versucht, diese ukrainischen Kräfte zu umfassen.
Nun haben wir Anfang Mai und die
Situation ist die, dass dieser russische
Angriff offensichtlich nicht den Verlauf nimmt,
den man erwartet hat. Wir sehen zwar, dass es an
mehreren Stellen der kurzen Umfassung Erfolge der
russischen Seite gibt. Aber offensichtlich ist der
ukrainische Widerstand so groß, dass es nicht
zu einem Durchbruch und einem Vorstoß in die
Tiefe kommt - und warum, das wollen wir uns jetzt
im Detail ansehen. Wenn wir uns den russischen
Vormarsch ansehen, so erkennen wir zwar, dass
sie gemäß russischer Doktrin vorgehen. Das heißt:
Einsatz der Kräfte überlegt und abgestimmt auf
die verschiedenen Fähigkeiten wie Artillerie oder
Luftunterstützung. Aber trotzdem ist es nicht so,
dass die russischen Kräfte rasch Gelände gewinnen,
das sie brauchen, um dann in die Tiefe vorstoßen
zu können. Wir nehmen nun vier Faktoren, anhand
derer wir uns die Situation ansehen. Der erste
Faktor ist das Gelände selbst. Wir erkennen hier,
dass im zentralen Raum des Kessels der Vormarsch
an vier Stellen passiert bzw. parallel dazu weiter
im Südwesten ein Vormarsch zumindest begonnen
worden ist. Wenn wir uns das Gelände ansehen,
so erkennen wir, dass sich erstens die ukrainische
Seite offensichtlich in mehreren tiefgestaffelten
Verteidigungslinien eingerichtet hat. Das heißt,
man geht davon aus, dass es zum Beispiel im Kessel
selbst zumindest drei Verteidigungslinien gibt,
die hier die russische Seite aufhalten. Der
nächste Faktor des Geländes, der einschränkend für
die russische Seite ist, ist der Bewuchs und die
Struktur des Geländes. Man erkennt es hier sehr
gut: Die Russen haben eine Zeit lang gebraucht,
um aus diesem Raum, der einerseits bewaldet ist
bzw. auch von einem Fluss durchflossen wird,
entsprechend heraustreten zu können, um dann die
nördliche Zange zu entwickeln. Eine Situation
wie auch im Westen, wo der Dnjepr ganz klar die
nächste starke Verteidigungslinie darstellt. Als
zweiten Faktor sehen wir uns nun die Kräfte und
die Kräfte-Gegenüberstellung an. Auf dieser Skizze
kann man erkennen, dass auf ukrainischer Seite
insgesamt 27 Brigade-Äquivalente bereitgestellt
sind. Eine Brigade der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
hat in etwa drei Bataillone. Das heißt,
wir reden von insgesamt 81 Bataillonen, die
sich hier befinden. Auf der russischen Seite
gehen die westlichen Medien aber auch die
westlichen Nachrichtendienste davon aus,
dass wir 93 Bataillonstaktische Gruppen im Einsatz
haben. Das heißt, wir haben ein Verhältnis von 81
zu 93. Wenn wir uns die Situation in dem möglichen
Kessel ansehen, dann sehen wir ein Verhältnis von
48 Bataillonen zu 68 Bataillonen. Das heißt: Das
Verhältnis, das der Angreifer braucht - nämlich
1:4 - wird von russischer Seite nicht erfüllt.
Denn bei näherer Betrachtung stellt man fest,
dass die Kräfte in etwa gleich sind bzw.
die ukrainische Seite auch den Vorteil hat,
dass ihre Kräfte massiv eingegraben sind. Ein
weiterer Faktor ist die Zeit. Um eine Operation
rasch und zielgerichtet entwickeln zu können,
ist es ganz entscheidend, schnell zu agieren.
Hier war das Problem der Russen, wenn Sie
sich jetzt zurückerinnern an das Gelände:
Dass sie am Beginn Zeit brauchten, um aus dem
schwierigen Gelände heraustreten zu können,
um sich bereitzustellen für diesen Angriff, der
vorgesehen war in Richtung Süden. Wir erkennen
das hier am Beispiel von Isjum. Das ist eine
kleine Stadt, die eingebettet ist zwischen zwei
schwierigen Geländeteilen, die vor allem bewaldet
sind, und zusätzlich noch die Herausforderung hat,
dass ein Fluss - der Siwerskyj Donez - durch
diesen Raum fließt. Die ukrainische Verteidigung
hat sich an dieses Gelände angelehnt. Der
erste Angriff der Russen wurde abgewehrt.
Es hat also eine Zeit lang gedauert, bis die
russische Seite durch dieses bewaldete Gebiet,
das eigentlich für den Einsatz von mechanisierten
Kräften nicht geeignet ist, umfassen konnte,
zwei Ponton-Brücken gelegt hat und dann von hier
aus weiter angetreten ist und es tatsächlich
geschafft hat, die ukrainische Seite in der
Tiefe zu umfassen und zu zerschlagen. Erst
dann waren die Voraussetzungen geschaffen,
sich hier bereitzustellen für einen weiteren
Angriff Richtung Süden. Das hat natürlich
Zeit gekostet, die in der Operationsführung
gefehlt hat. Nach der Umfassung und dem
Legen der Ponton-Brücken, war es möglich,
Kräfte über den Fluss in einen Bereitstellungsraum
zu bringen. Dazu haben einerseits Kampfpanzer aber
auch motorisierte Elemente gezählt, aber natürlich
auch die Artillerie. Dieser Bereitstellungsraum
wurde erweitert und man hat begonnen, diesen
Angriff Richtung Süden durchzuführen. Der nächste
Faktor, der entscheidend ist, ist Information.
Die russische Seite versucht laufend, sich ein
Lagebild über den Einsatz der ukrainischen
Kräfte zu schaffen. Dazu werden vor allem
Drohnen eingesetzt. Es gelingt den ukrainischen
Kräften immer wieder, diese Drohnen abzuschießen,
wie zum Beispiel hier dieses System "Orlan-10",
was es für die Russen schwierig macht,
sich tatsächlich ein Lagebild zu verschaffen und
vor allem die eigene Kampfunterstützung - also
die Artillerie - zielgerichtet einzusetzen.
Besonders das Lagebild ist für die russische
Seite wichtig, denn der Einsatz der Kräfte
orientiert sich natürlich an der Positionierung
der ukrainischen Streitkräfte. Wir sehen hier ein
Beispiel einer ukrainischen Stellung. Einmal mit
vorgelagerten Schützengräben, aber auch hier an
der Geländekante mit zusätzlichen Schützengräben
und auch Unterständen. Die russische Seite
versucht nun, diese Positionen aufzuklären
und gezielt mit Artillerie zu beschießen. Die
relativ leichten ukrainischen Kräfte hingegen
können bei einem Vorstoßen der russischen Kräfte
zum Beispiel mit Panzerabwehrwaffen relativ reicht
die russische Seite schwer treffen und abnützen.
Das heißt, man erkennt, dass die ukrainische Seite
die letzten Jahre genutzt hat, um sich hier massiv
einzugraben. Zusätzlich ist es so, dass es immer
wieder zur sogenannten mobilen Verteidigung
kommt. Das heißt: Vor einem Artillerie-Schlag
versuchen die Ukrainer, auszuweichen oder in die
Unterstände zu gehen und dann erst beim Antreten
der Russen die Stellungen wieder zu beziehen
und entsprechend einen Abwehrerfolg zu erzielen.
Die Russen versuchen, dieser Taktik der Ukraine
entgegenzuwirken, indem sie massiv Artillerie
einsetzen. Einerseits haben wir immer
öfter den Einsatz dieser thermobarischen
Raketenwerfer vom Typ TOS-1 oder TOS-1A, aber
auch von Mehrfach-Raketenwerfern vom Typ BM-30
oder BM-27. Nach diesem vorbereitenden
Artilleriefeuer, erst dann wird versucht,
mit mechanisierten Kräften, unterstützt von
Infanterie, langsam vorzumarschieren. Das hat
aber natürlich die Herausforderung, dass
die überlebenden Kräfte der ukrainischen
Seite mit Panzerabwehrwaffen den Russen
immer wieder Verluste beibringen können.
Wir wissen auch, dass die ukrainische Seite
vermutlich in der Tiefe Kräfte bereitgestellt hat,
wenn die russische Seite tatsächlich einen
Durchbruch erzielen sollte, um diesen Durchbruch
anzugreifen - also die nördliche oder die südliche
Zange. Dazu brauchen sie einerseits Panzer,
aber auch Schützenpanzer beziehungsweise auch
andererseits die Fähigkeit, diese Kräfte einen
Angriff durchführen zu lassen. Darum ist die
Lieferung von diesen "Gepard"-Panzern so wichtig.
Denn nur durch den Einsatz der "Gepard"-Panzer
würde es gelingen, die russische Seite daran zu
hindern, diesen Angriff aufzuhalten. Denn der
Vorteil der russischen Seite ist: Sie haben die
Luftüberlegenheit im Donbass. Das heißt, sie
erleiden zwar immer wieder Verluste, aber sie
können wo sie möchten mit ihren Kampfflugzeugen
und Kampfhubschraubern zuschlagen. Das heißt,
ein derartiger Gegenangriff der ukrainischen
Seite kann nur funktionieren, wenn es gelingt,
die russische Seite daran zu hindern, ihn
zu zerschlagen. Auf russischer Seite werden
eingesetzt: Erdkampfflugzeuge vom Typ SU-25,
aber auch Kampfhubschrauber. Das heißt, durch die
mitgeführten Fliegerabwehrsysteme der ukrainischen
Seite wäre es möglich, diese so zu neutralisieren,
dass dieser ukrainische Gegenangriff tatsächlich
einen Raum gewinnen kann. Die Frage ist nun, wenn
wir uns diese Situation ansehen: Wie wird sich die
Situation in den nächsten Wochen weiterentwickeln
bzw. wer entscheidet möglicherweise diese
Schlacht für sich? Es gibt einige Faktoren,
die eine wichtige Rolle spielen. Ich habe schon
die Bedeutung von Artillerie betont. Wir haben
auf der einen Seite, auf der russischen Seite,
massiven Artillerie-Einsatz, dem man jetzt von
ukrainischer Seite versucht entgegenzuwirken.
Und man erkennt, dass die Waffenlieferungen von
westlicher Seite - ob das jetzt als Beispiel
gezogene Geschütze sind wie aus den USA,
oder auch motorisierte Einheiten auf Rädern
oder Selbstfahrlafette - gerade genau in diese
Richtung zielen: Also Artilleriesysteme den
Ukrainern zur Verfügung zu stellen, um die
russischen Artilleriesysteme auszuschalten. Der
zweite Faktor, der hier ganz wesentlich ist, ist
dass wir im Prinzip auf beiden Seiten
diesen Versuch erkennen können: Nämlich
auch die russische Seite versucht, durch das
Heranführen von zusätzlichen Artilleriesystemen
(einerseits Mehrfachraketenwerfern aber
auch schwerer Belagerungsartillerie,
wie zum Beispiel von diesen 203-mm-Geschützen)
- die ukrainische Seite sukzessive abzunützen,
in der Hoffnung, sie so abzunützen, dass sie
bevor die westlichen Waffensysteme eintreffen,
einen entsprechenden Angriff durchführen kann,
der durchbricht. Es gibt natürlich noch andere
Faktoren, die eine Rolle spielen. Zum Beispiel:
Wenn es der russischen Seite tatsächlich gelingen
sollte, etwa im Norden bei Isjum durchzubrechen,
könnte es sein, dass wir den bereits angekündigten
Einsatz von Kamikaze-Drohen sehen, der dann
diesem Vorstoß der russischen Seite ein Ende
setzt. Wir dürfen aber auch nicht vergessen, dass
die russische Seite versucht, dies zu unterbinden.
Das heißt, sie konzentriert sich nicht nur auf
den Donbass, sondern versucht vor allem in der
Tiefe des Landes, die Waffenlieferungen in den
Donbass zu unterbrechen. Sie setzt dabei ihre
Luftstreitkräfte ein, wie zum Beispiel diese
MiG-31, mit diesem Hyperschall-Flugkörper,
oder auch unterschiedlichste Systeme ballistischer
Raketen aber auch von Cruise Missiles, die wir
täglich seit dem 24. Februar im Einsatz sehen.
Ein gutes Beispiel für diese Absicht haben wir in
den letzten 10 Tagen gesehen. Immer wieder hat
die russische Seite versucht, in der Tiefe des
Landes ganz gezielt vor allem die Struktur der
Eisenbahn-Einrichtungen zu treffen, indem sie die
Umspannwerke und Trafo-Stationen der ukrainischen
Seite angegriffen hat - in der Hoffnung, aufgrund
des nicht mehr verfügbaren elektrifizierten
Netzes eine Reduktion der Transporte zu
erfüllen, weil die ukrainische Seite, dadurch dass
sie ihre Elektro-Loks nicht mehr benützen kann,
auf Diesel-Loks zurückgreifen muss. Interessant
waren vor allem die Angriffe in den letzten Tagen,
wo zum Beispiel auch bei einem Tunnel in den
Beskiden ganz gezielt versucht worden ist,
die dortige Trafo-Station für die Versorgung zu
unterbrechen. Das heißt, man kann hier also klar
erkennen: Die Absicht der Russen, hier
entsprechend durch Interdiction zu verhindern,
dass diese westlichen Waffensysteme rechtzeitig
zur Schlacht im Donbass eintreffen. Nach dieser
Lagedarstellung möchte ich kurz einen Blick
in die Vergangenheit werfen und versuchen,
anhand eines historischen Beispiels
einen Rückschluss darauf zuzulassen,
wie diese Situation sich möglicherweise in den
nächsten Tagen und Wochen weiter entwickeln kann.
Tatsächlich ist es so, dass es im selben Raum
1943 bereits zu einer Kesselschlacht gekommen ist,
nämlich die berühmte Schlacht von Kursk
- das deutsche Unternehmen "Zitadelle",
das nördlich von Charkiw stattgefunden hat.
Hier war es so, dass die sowjetische Seite
einen Frontvorbogen Richtung Westen gehalten hat
und die deutsche Seite versucht hat, in einer
Zangenbewegung aus dem Norden und aus dem Süden
dieses sowjetische Kräfte-Dispositiv einzukesseln.
Die Situation heute ist sehr ähnlich: Südlich
von Charkiw haben wir ebenfalls einen Frontbogen,
diesmal der ukrainischen Seite, in Richtung
Osten und die russische Seite versucht, in zwei
Zangenbewegungen aus dem Norden und aus dem Süden,
dieses ukrainische Kräfte-Dispositiv einzukesseln.
Wenn wir uns den Ausgang der Schlacht von Kursk
1943 ansehen, so sind sich die Historiker einig,
dass es im Wesentlichen drei Faktoren waren,
die diese Schlacht für die sowjetische Seite
entschieden haben. Der erste Faktor war,
dass die sowjetische Seite sehr genau wusste,
wo und zu welcher Zeit diese deutschen Angriffe
stattfinden werden - man nimmt an, aufgrund der
Entschlüsselung einer deutschen Chiffrier-Maschine
vom Typ "Enigma". Der zweite Faktor war,
dass sich die sowjetische Seite monatelang
sehr exakt auf diesen Angriff vorbereitet
hat und Verteidigungsstellungen in der Tiefe, vor
allem in den Flanken, errichtet hat - zur Abwehr
des deutschen Angriffs. Und der dritte Faktor
war die Verbissenheit der sowjetischen Soldaten
beim Kampf bzw. bei der Abwehr dieser deutschen
Angriffe und am Ende musste die deutsche Seite
diese beiden Zangenbewegungen abbrechen und
die sowjetische Seite konnte die Schlacht für
sich entscheiden. Wenn wir diese Situation in den
Donbass übertragen, so sehen wir, dass diese drei
Faktoren offensichtlich auch hier zur Anwendung
kommen. Der erste Faktor ist, dass offensichtlich
die ukrainische Seite sehr genau Bescheid weiß
über die Art und Weise der russischen Angriffe.
Der zweite Faktor ist, dass sich die ukrainische
Seite sogar jahrelang vorbereitet hat und tief
gestaffelte Verteidigungsstellungen eingerichtet
hat in Erwartung des russischen Angriffs. Und
der dritte Faktor, unbestritten seit Beginn der
Angriffe auf die Ukraine: die Verbissenheit der
ukrainischen Soldaten, die quasi jeden Meter Boden
verteidigen - mit der Absicht, die russische Seite
so abzunützen, dass dieser Angriff schlussendlich
scheitert und nicht den Erfolg bringt, den sich
die russische Seite erwartet. Zum Schluss möchte
ich Ihnen diese Videosequenz und dieses Standbild
aus dieser Sequenz zeigen. Sie erkennen hier die
Situation der ukrainischen Soldaten im Donbass.
Wir sehen eine Schützengrabenlinie, die sich
von Nord bis Süd zieht. Wir erkennen Krater von
den Einschlägen der russischen Artillerie in den
letzten Tagen bzw. sehen wir hier auch gerade den
Einschlag einer russischen Artilleriegranate.
Die ukrainischen Soldaten, die wir hier
erkennen können, versuchen diesen Einschlägen
auszuweichen, indem sie in den Schützengräben
Schutz suchen. Dieses Bild soll Ihnen zeigen,
dass wir eine Situation haben, die sehr an den
Ersten Weltkrieg erinnert: Verdun 1916, also einen
Stellungskrieg, wo beide Seiten versucht haben,
durch den massiven Einsatz von Artillerie
sich abzunützen. Die russische Seite versucht,
die Stellungen der Ukraine zu zerschlagen,
um angreifen zu können. Die ukrainische Seite
versucht, die Russen so abzunützen, dass dieser
Angriff nicht mehr möglich ist. Damit bin ich am
Ende meiner Ausführungen und ich sage herzlichen
Dank fürs Zuschauen. Bis zum nächsten Mal!